vous avez 85 devant c'est à la mode des
années 80 j'étais fan je regrette rosa
période de la veste en jean fourré le
petit cropped top le lead-in bientôt
c'était mes années politique l'alecso
mitterrand en 81 et ce qui m'a vraiment
impressionné c'est la catastrophe de
tchernobyl
star wars grâce à star wars le premier
là j'attends le prochain régime empire
contre attaque
la boue la boum voiture à la future luke
je suis ton père inconnu non c'est
l'ordinateur la bbc c'était pas ma
guerre vous avez la pâte en baie du sud
alors sur la patte de mouche qui pète
kreposuk terminator sarah connor sarah
connor bb bag
michael jackson voilà c'est la voix un
peu éraillée la fait pas partie du week
end à rome tellement tellement tellement
je sais plus trop bien quoi être une
je peux la faire à l'infini il
m'entraîne au bout de la nuit jusqu'au
bout de la besoin de rien envie de toi
comme jamais envie de m je sais j'ai des
bouts de chou
c'est pourtant
grâce à ça va princes et princesses des
capuches santa barbara tu me le dira
pourquoi j'ai le mal de vivre
un stand univers impitoyable la dre
parker capitaine flam capitaine flint
une bande notre galaxie
mais du fond de la nuit thème les
derniers dinosaures c'est mon horizon
plus encore